Kimberly is with us in Knoxville hi
Kimberly welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi mr. Ramsey thank you for taking my
call my question is about my car she's
my car was in the collision and the
insurance company wants these are
awesome these fifty seven hundred and
they take the car or I keep my car and
they'll give me forty seven hundred but
I have to fix the car what should I do
mmm-hmm what is the car worth the car is
about seven thousand seventy five
hundred okay so why are you only getting
fifty seven hundred for it my deductible
is a thousand and they took off for some
things in the car is the 2002 Nissan
Sentra's heard only has seventy one
thousand miles on it so it would take
you seven thousand dollars to buy this
car a replacement car just like it
probably even more because it's a sr
version so probably more eight thousand
they wouldn't have that many miles on it
would probably have more what kind of
damage does it have runnin it's got
fender damage and I'm not sure all what
else but I could tell the light is out
and it was considered totaled well the
totaling is not the damage the totaling
is the percentage of value okay so do
you have any money I do have some I have
forty thousand in savings but this maybe
make a difference I'm the only one
working right now my husband's a nurse
actually just cool mhm and we're kind of
funding we're cash flowing their school
mm-hmm okay well here's the way it lays
out in my mind we can either fix this
car and drive it and that doesn't cost
you anything out of pocket right there
just always caused me yeah well no
they're gonna pay for the repair you
told me that no we considered it a loss
so they're not gonna pay their either
pay fifty seven hundred
and I can go and buy another beater or
4700 and I can keep the car and we could
cut repairs on my own yeah can you do
the repairs for 4700 I don't know well I
don't want to hope so I want to know I
mean go get a bit go get an estimate and
if you can do the repairs for 4700 do
you want to do the repairs for 4700 and
fix the car or do you want to put a
little bit of money with your 5700 like
a thousand bucks and get you a car
basically the equivalent of what you had
it sounds like this car needs to be
replaced to me it's been hit hard yeah
and I'm not sure I want to fix this car
so I'm probably putting a thousand
dollars with the fifty seven hundred and
buying me a car okay doesn't matter if
I'm in thirty-nine thousand dollars of
debt student loan no it's a thousand
dollars that we're talking about here I
mean you're basically breaking even on
the car you can buy that car for sixty
seven hundred dollars roughly I mean
give or take a car just like that that's
the value of the car and if they're
going to give you a check for five
thousand seven hundred dollars I would
take it okay thanks for the call hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]